tareg guitare est une cible se juge en
charge de l'enquêté sur l'explosion
survenue dans le port de beyrouth le 4
août 2020 a été contraint une nouvelle
fois de la suspendre le 23 décembre
dernier le juge bittar a été informé
d'un recours présenté par les anciens
ministres ali hassan khalil et ghazi
zeaiter il a donc été contraint à
suspendre l'enquète au total 18 plaintes
ont été déposées à l'encontre du
magistrat c'est la quatrième fois que l'
enquête et suspendu depuis février 2021
date à laquelle ce juge a été choisi
pour mener les investigations
il faut dire que tarek bitar entendait
poursuivre pour négligence des
responsables politiques ces derniers
étaient semble-t-il au courant de la
menace constituée par le stockage de
nitrate d'ammonium dans l'entrepôt qui a
explosé ce sont ces mêmes responsables
politiques parmi lesquels figurent
d'anciens ministres et députés et qui
ont donc déposé plainte contre le juge
les appels à remplacer tarek guitare se
sont multipliées dans la classe
politique libanaise ces dernières
semaines certains ont même annoncé qu'il
boycotterait les réunions du cabinet
tant qu'ils ne seraient pas remplacés
noter que le gouvernement ne s'est pas
réuni depuis le 12 octobre dernier et
que le ministère de l'intérieur n'a pas
exécuter les mandats d'arrêt émis par le
juge bitar le corps judiciaire au liban
est malade certains juges ne sont qu'une
caisse de résonance des leaders
politiques qui les ont nommés en février
dernier le juge fadi sawan avait lui
aussi été écarté de l'enquète début
septembre sont 40 ong ont appelé le
conseil des droits de l'homme de l'onu a
diligenté une enquête internationale
indépendante
parce qu'à l'évidence l'enquète
libanaise patine et laisse les familles
des victimes dans le désarroi
679 plaintes ont été déposées devant la
justice au nom des familles des victimes
des blessés et des personnes affectées
par l'explosion